如內心有夢 便全力追蹤
不須計那天才可終
好比天空疾勁野風
撞到人了
撞到人喇
過去看一下
過去睇下
阿伯 撞哪了
阿伯 你撞到邊度啊
好痛
好痛啊
哪裡痛
邊度痛啊
不知道 哪裡都痛
唔知呢 度度都痛囉
我扶你起來
我扶你起身
動不了
郁唔到啊
是不是撞車黨啊 真的假的
係咪撞車黨啊 真定假的㗎
喂 警察啊 這裡有車禍
喂 999啊 呢度撞左車
我現在在大鵬
我而家係大鵬
阿伯 我都是個演員
阿伯 我都係個演員嚟嘅
以撞車黨來說痛的表達是非常重要的
撞車黨嚟講呢 痛嘅表達係非常之咁重要嘅
我都不覺得你痛 哪有說服力呢
我都唔覺得你痛 咁邊度有說服力呢
哎呀
略嫌有點隨便
略嫌求其啊
你現在是給車撞了 你就哎呀一聲
你依家比車撞呀 你哎呀咁
這怎可過關呢
點過到骨啊
你都演不到位觀眾沒法同情你
你係都唔交足戲 啲觀眾好難同情你㗎喎
真的好痛
真係好痛
不要嚇我吧 大哥
唔好嚇我啦 哥哥
這麼差怎謀生 認真點
搵食㗎喎 認真啲啊
你看我
你睇我
我暈了
我暈喇
你又做什麼 大哥 不要自作聰明
你又做咩呀 哥哥 唔好叻唔切啦
暈倒前要扶一下頭 要鋪排一下
暈之前你要扶一扶個頭先 要鋪排㗎嘛
連血漿都有準備
血漿都有準備喎
但你前面表演真的太差了
但你前面啲戲呢確係太屎啦
現在就算加條恐龍 也補救不了
依家就算加條恐龍呢 都救唔番
大家同行交流一下
大家同行交流下姐
不要介意
唔好擺係心度呀
救護車來了 讓開
救護車嚟啦 讓開
讓一下
借借
左胸口第三肋骨輕微骨折 沒有生命危險
左胸口第三肋骨輕微骨折 無生命危險
上擔架床
上擔架
準備 起
小心點
小心啲吓
對不起 阿伯
對唔住啊 阿伯
那個女的是家屬嗎
嗰個女人係家屬啊
她是傻的 別理她
佢係傻㗎 唔駛理佢
救命啊
我的腿
我隻腳啊
停
Cut
你個臨時演員在幹什麼 會不會演戲
你個茄哩啡係度做咩啊 識唔識做戲㗎
受傷一點聲音都沒有 怎能出來混飯吃
受傷一啲聲都無 點出嚟撈啊
是這樣 根據我個人經驗
係咁嘅 根據我個人嘅經驗呢
人在痛苦的時候不一定要大喊大叫的
人係痛苦嘅時候係唔一定要鬼剎咁嘈嘅
你說什麼
你噏乜啊
大叔 你過來一下
阿叔 你過一過嚟吔
麻煩你做個痛苦的反應看看
麻煩你做個痛苦反應睇下
啊
這個是假的
嗱呢啲係假嘅
幫幫忙
幫幫手
這就是真的 沒有聲音吧
呢啲係真㗎啦 無聲㗎
你跟導演說說
你同導演講吓
導演 你覺得呢
導演 你點睇啊
- 我 - 導演
你
滾遠點
死遠啲啦
喂喂喂
需要演死屍的 死人妝兩天不能卸
需要演死屍嘅 死人妝兩日唔落得
- 多少錢 - 誰願意去
- 幾多錢 - 有無人做
兩天四百
兩日四百
加點吧
加啲啦
我來我來
我嚟我嚟
看見臉的嗎
見唔見到樣嘅先
你跟我講條件
你同我講條件啊
看見臉 我不要錢 有飯盒就行
見樣 唔收錢 飯盒就得㗎啦
成交 走
有沒有搞錯
有冇搞錯
神經病
痴線
大家先吃吧 要不涼了
大家食飯先 唔係餸都凍晒啦
你是壽星公 你不吃
你係壽星公 你唔食
誰敢吃啊
邊個夠膽食啊
爸
阿爸
生日快樂
小夢
今天你的妝很特別
今日你嗰裝好特別喎
給你嚇到了
比你嚇親啊
你拍戲好好玩
你拍戲好好玩呀可
我這次演一個死屍
今次呢我演條死屍
有特寫鏡頭的 可以看到演技
有大頭鏡頭 會見到我演技㗎
死屍都能看出演技
死屍都仲睇得到演技
爸
對於一個演員來說 死亡是一種有趣的設定
對於一個演員嚟講 死亡係一種好有趣嘅設定
你想像下
你想像一下
如果你被活生生地砍死了
如果你尷生比人砍死左
那種意境確是
嗰種意境確係
你說什麼
你講咩啊
再說一次
講多次啊
你今天生日不要動氣
你今日生日唔好咁勞氣啦
小夢 不要亂說話 快把妝給卸了
小夢 唔好亂嗡嘢 快啲去落左個妝佢
明天還要繼續拍
聽日仲要繼續拍啊
你真的以為自己是大明星嗎
你真係以為自己係大明星啊
你們是一起長大的吧
你地一齊大㗎係嘛
你看人家B仔
你睇人地B仔呀
已經是大律師了
已經係大律師啦
小小成就何足掛齒
你再看豬豬
你再睇下豬豬啊
多幸福
幾幸福
找到個這麼好的老公
搵到個咁好嘅老公
你再看看你自己
你再睇下你自己
我們希望你當大律師的
我地想你做律師㗎
不是死屍
唔係死屍啊
行行出狀元 律師和死屍都不分貴賤
行行出狀元 律師和死屍都無分貴賤啊
我做臨時演員都是自食其力
我做茄哩啡都係自食其力啊
我也有我的夢想
我都有我嘅夢想㗎
你都三十歲了 做臨時演員都十幾年了
你三十歲啦 茄哩啡做左十幾年嗱
當女主角了嗎
做左女主角未呀
我相信憑我的天賦 加上我的努力
我相信憑我嘅天賦 加上我嘅努力
肯定是最佳女主角
肯定係最佳女主角
對不起 嗆著了
對唔全 濁親
媽 你說對不對
阿媽 你話係咪
你一定可以的
你實得嘅
可以個屁
得個屁
都是你把她寵壞了
一日最衰就係你縱壞佢
不要說我這個爸不給你多一次機會
咪話我做老豆嘅唔比多次機會你
砍死你的這菜刀 給我燒了它
你頭上個把死人刀 同我燒左佢
菜刀能燒的嗎
菜刀燒得著嘅咩
不能燒就砍死你
燒唔著我就砍死你
砍死你
等等
爸 你剛跳起那一下 情緒很飽滿
阿爸 正話你跳起個下 情緒好飽滿啊
你拿著刀再跳一次
你乸起把刀再跳一次
我錄下來
我錄低佢
來 預備跳
嚟 預備 跳
跳吧
跳呀喂
女 你搞什麼
囡 你做乜啊
阿姨 我們先走了
阿姨 我地先走啦
真的不好意思
真係唔好意思啊
滾
扯
我沒生過你
我冇生過你
把你的垃圾都帶走
攞埋你啲垃圾走
爸 這些垃圾是你的
阿爸 呢啲垃圾係你㗎喎
我管它是誰的
我理得你邊個啊
爛泥扶不上牆
爛泥扶唔上牆
不要給我再看見你
你唔好再比我見到你
好了好了 吵夠了 吵夠了嗎
好啦好啦 嘈夠啦 嘈夠未啊
我見你一次打你一次
我見你一鑊打你一鑊
喂
有沒有會做反應的
有冇人識做反應㗎
有
你
做個開心的反應
做個開心反應
傷心反應
好 過來
掂呀 過嚟呀
生氣的反應誰會
嬲嘅反應邊個嚟
我
你
仆街吧
仆街呀你
你來
你嚟
好 非常好
ok 正呀
中絕招的反應誰來
中絕招反應邊個嚟
我
你
請問我具體來說是中了什麼絕招呢
請問我具體嚟講中左咩絕招呢
你問這麼多幹嘛 你可以就做 不可以就滾開
你問咁多嘢做咩呀 你做到就做 做唔到就死開啦
寒冰掌吧
寒冰掌啦
好 寒冰掌
好冷 真的好冷
好冷 好冷啊
你有病就去看病 別在這傳染我
有病去睇醫生啦 唔好係度惹埋我啊
你試試
你試吓
你拉我來這幹什麼 我走了
你帶我嚟呢度做咩嘢呀 我走啦
煲了湯給她喝嘛
煲左湯比佢飲呀嘛
還給她煲湯 這明顯是跟我對著干
仲同佢煲湯 姐係擺明同我作對姐
你就當順道來看一下女兒
你咪當順便嚟睇下個女囉
我見她我就揍她 到時候你別攔著我
我見佢就打鑊佢 到時你唔好攔住我啊
要不連你一塊揍
唔係我連你都打
我都特意避開你 你還送過要來給我罵 你真賤格
我都專登避開你㗎啦 你係都要送埋嚟被我剷嘅 你咁賤格嘅你
要你做個反應要什麼前因後果
叫你做個反應講咩前因後果
我只是想令這角色立體一點
我都係想令個角色立體一啲
立你的命吧 立體
立你條毛咩 立體
都看不見你的臉 你以為你是主演嗎
都見唔到你個死樣 你以為自己係主角啊
跟你說前文後理 你懂嗎
同你講前文後理 你識條鐵咩
懂就不會在這裡做臨時演員
識嘅話就唔駛係度做茄哩啡啦
走 跟我來
走 跟我嚟
好激動
你好
誰呀
邊位呀
好好的說話可以嗎
好好哋講嘢唔得咩
人家演員問你問題 需要發這麼大脾氣嗎
人地演員問你少少問題 需要發咁大脾氣咩
關你屁事
關你鬼事
她對表演這麼認真 你看不見嗎
佢對表演咁認真 你睇唔到咩
誰呀
邊個呀
我說誰你心裡清楚
我講邊個你心照啊
人在做 天在看
小心遭報應
因住比雷劈
神經病 場務
痴線 場務
不好意思
唔好意思啊
你知道我是誰嗎
你知唔知我係邊個呀
不知道
唔知
- 那就好 - 走吧
咁就得嘞 走啦
你好
hi
你剛剛做的那反應很有層次 我覺得很到位
你啱啱做嗰個反應好有層次喎 我覺得好到位
還好吧
算係咁啦
關鍵是想像力 你一定要用心去體會當時的情境
關鍵係想像力 你一定要用心去體會當時嘅情境
太厲害了
真係犀利
我叫李洋
我叫如夢
你也在看這本書
你都睇緊呢本書啊
對啊
係呀
你也喜歡喜劇之王
你都鐘意喜劇之王咩
何止 反轉都會背呀
何止啊 反轉都識背呀
要不要來一段
不如走番轉
現在
依家
不然等什麼
唔係幾時啊
喂
什麼
點呀
走啦
走嗱
是啊
係呀
去哪兒
去邊呀
回家
返屋企
然後呢
上班
返工
不上班行不行
唔返工得唔得呀
不上班你養我
不上班你養我啊
喂
又怎麼了
又點呀
我養你啊
我男朋友來了
我男朋友嚟左啦
錯了 對白不是這樣
錯左 對白唔係咁
不是不是 真是我男朋友來了
唔係呀唔係呀 真係我男朋友嚟呀
走了
走啦
誰啊
邊個嚟㗎
一起工作的
一齊做嘢㗎
真的
真嘅
真的 走吧 再見
係呀 走啦 拜拜
我這條香腸也給你
我呢條腸仔都比埋你呀
一人一半
一人一半啦
我這個月工資有四千 存到我們的結婚基金裡
我呢個月出四千蚊糧 入落我哋個結婚基金啊
你一個月最多賺五千 你給我四千
你一個月最多搵五千 你比四千蚊我
你怎麼生活
你仲點夠洗啊
我有一千就夠了
我有一千蚊名用啦
劇組裡有飯盒 我不用花錢
劇組又有飯盒 我都無錢要洗
我出四千五
我出四千五啦
這五百還給你
呢五百比番你
不是說好了嗎
咪講好左㗎囉
一人一半嗎
一人一半㗎嘛
我以為我愛你夠深
沒想到你愛我一樣深
估唔到你愛我一樣夠深
你真把錢給他呀
你真係比錢佢啊
對啊
係呀
為什麼你不把錢給我
又唔見你比錢我嘅
我又不跟你結婚
我又唔係同你結婚
你跟他還不如跟我
你同佢不如同我好過啦
香皂借我用一下
借舊番皂嚟用呀
你為何一直盯著小米看 你是不是喜歡她
你做咩係咁望住小米呀 你係咪鐘意佢啫
你這樣說我就生氣了
你咁講我就好嬲嘞
看就是喜歡嗎
望就係鐘意咩
看她是否這麼低俗
望佢係睇下佢係咪咁 cheap
她就是這麼低俗
佢真係咁 cheap
你不覺得小米很漂亮嗎
你唔覺得小米好靚女咩
漂亮了不起啊
靚唔係大晒㗎
沒內涵
冇內涵
你知道我為什麼愛你嗎
你知唔知點解我咁愛你呀
為什麼
點解
因為你有品味
當然了
梗係啦
對了
呀係啦
我想帶你去見我爸媽
我想帶你去見我阿爸阿媽
如果他們知道我們在一起 定會很放心
如果佢地知道我哋係埋一齊 真會好放心啫
當然了
當然啦
其實我正在搞一個大項目
其實呢近排我係度搞緊一個大項目
等這事成功之後
等呢件事成功左之後
你爸媽一定會以我為驕傲的
你阿爸阿媽一定會以我為驕傲嘅
你千萬不要告訴別人 我查理
你千祈唔好講比人聽 我查理
就是下一個比爾 . 蓋茨
就係下一個比爾 . 蓋茨
你一來就想當世界第一
你一嚟就想做世界第一
不如先從第二第三開始 會不會踏實些
不如從第二第三開始先啦 會唔會踏實啲呀
我是最踏實的
我係最踏實嘅
比爾 . 蓋茨有幾隻眼睛
比爾 . 蓋茨有幾多隻眼睛
兩隻
我有幾隻眼睛
我有幾多隻眼睛
兩隻
他不比我多 我不比他少
佢無多過我 我無少過佢
對不對 對
係咪先 係呀
他能做到的 我一樣能做到
咁佢可以做到嘅 我一樣可以做到
很有道理
好有道理喎
所以 你要相信自己是最好的
所以 你要相信自己係最好嘅
不是第二第三 你就是第一
唔係第二第三 你就係第一
不要再想著拍什麼網大網劇
唔好再諗住拍咩網大網劇
要拍就拍國際大片
最近真的有一套國際大片 在這裡招中國演員
最近真係有一套國際大片 係呢度搵緊中國演員啊
這就是你的機會了
呢個就係你嘅機會啦
但是那角色是白雪公主
但係個角色係白雪公主喎
你就是白雪公主
你就係白雪公主
我
白雪公主有幾隻眼睛
兩隻
那你有幾隻眼睛
你有幾隻眼睛
兩隻
那為什麼你不能是白雪公主
咁點解你唔可以係白雪公主
告訴我 為什麼
話我知 點解
說啊
講呀嘛
問心吧
問心啦
是不是
係唔係先
有沒有道理
有無道理先
白雪公主
就是你
就係你
喂 你真要去打針啊
喂 你真係諗住去打針呀
因為白雪公主是西方名著
因為白雪公主係西方名著
我想樣子有點外國女子的氣質
所以我想個樣有啲鬼妹嘅氣質
這樣你都想得出來
咁都比你諗到呀
最頂級演員就是這樣
最頂級嘅演員就係咁㗎啦
馬龍 . 白蘭度為了爭取教父裡的角色
馬龍 . 白蘭度為左爭取教父呢嗰角色
花了很多功夫去改變臉型的
仲花左好多功夫去改變個臉型添
整容還不是為了漂亮 講那麼多廢話
整容咪唔係為左靚 仲講咁多廢話
你冤枉我
但是能變漂亮一點當然好
但係變靚啲嘅話 梗係最好啦
我發現了一個變美神器
我發現左一個變靚神器
新氧美容APP
裡面有好多正規機構和個案 做得挺好的
裡面有好多正規機構同個案 做得幾好嘅
我知道一家八十年的老字號
我識得有家八十年嘅老字號喎
在哪
係邊呀
到了
到啦
師傅 我介紹個客人給你
師傅 我介紹個客仔比你
想怎麼做啊
想點整呀
我想做成她這樣
我想整到好似佢咁
要那麼盡嗎
去到咁盡呀
對啊 我是第一次有點緊張
係呀 我第一次㗎咋 有啲緊張
這款我也是第一次 我也緊張
呢款我都係第一次 我都有啲緊張
師傅你是做中國人比較多 對吧
師傅你都係做開中國人多 係咪呀
不怕跟你說
唔怕話你知呀
我做人比較多一點
我做人比較多啲
毛你要做嗎
啲毛你係照整呀
什麼毛
咩毛啊
這全身的毛
咪成身啲毛囉
他們的毛確實比我們濃密
佢哋啲毛確係濃密過我哋嘅
不過一般來說都看不出來
不過一般嚟講都睇唔出㗎
很難看不出來
好難睇唔出㗎喎
你真是很專業 但毛我就不要了
你真係好專業啊 不過毛我就唔駛啦
那太浪費了
咁就嘥晒
這些效果只能維持一兩天
呢啲效果只能夠維持一兩日嘅啫
很簡單 很快就搞定
好簡單 好快趣搞掂㗎啦
師傅 我想把鼻子做得翹翹的
師傅 個鼻我想整到竅竅哋喎
你再翹就變成鴛鴦火鍋了
再竅就打邊爐鴛鴦鍋㗎啦
鴛鴦鍋
打邊爐
隨便吧 你喜歡就好
是但啦 你鐘意就得啦
師傅
你總是看那猩猩是什麼原理
你係咁望住隻猩猩係咩原理呀
我不看那猩猩怎麼整
我唔望住猩猩點整呀
為什麼呢
有啲咁嘅事
你要整成猩猩這樣嘛
你要整隻猩猩咁樣呀嘛
我不是要整這個
我唔係整呢個
是這個啊
係呢個呀
你不早說
你唔早啲講
我要照鏡子
我照照鏡先
你別照了 會把你嚇死的
你唔好照啦 咪一陣嚇死你啊
我幫你搞定 包在我身上
我幫你搞掂 包係我身上
躺下吧
訓低呀
好的 搞定了
好嘢 搞掂晒
整得怎麼樣 看看
整成點呀 睇下
可以嗎
得唔得呀
好美啊
好靚呀
真的嗎
係咪架
美到不得了
靚到鬼火咁啊
現在真不得了
嗱 而家真係好嘢啦
下一個
那邊等
過去等
幹什麼
做咩呀
我來試鏡
試什麼
試咩呀
白雪公主
為什麼
點解呀
因為我來試鏡白雪公主
因為我係嚟試白雪公主
你再說一次
你再講多次
為什麼說那麼多次
點解要講咁多次
我怕我聽錯
我驚我聽錯
我來試鏡白雪公主
我嚟試白雪公主
你再說一遍
你再講多次
算了 打擾了
咁由佢啦 打搞晒
站住 還走
企係度 仲走
給我攔住前面那東西
幫我截住前面隻嘢呀
手足快來幫忙 別讓她跑了
手足快啲過嚟幫忙 唔好比佢跑走
攔住她
攔住佢
抓住她
捉住佢
別走
唔好走呀
攔住她
攔住佢
跟我來
跟我嚟
還想跑
仲想走
看你走去哪裡
睇你走得去邊
還走
走啊嗱
對不起 我一時貪心才來試鏡的
對唔住 我一時貪心先嚟試鏡嘅
給我個機會
比次機會我呀
老闆你看
老闆你睇
怎處理
點處理
幹活
做嘢
不要啊
唔好呀
我以後都不敢了
我以後都唔敢㗎啦
頸圍三十三
開工 開工
袖長六十
為什麼呢
點解嘅
不要動
唔好郁
請問發生什麼事
請問發生咩事呢
我們選了你
我哋揀左你啦
導演 我這邊差不多準備好了
導演 我呢邊差唔多得啦
選了我
揀左我
我們隨時可以出發
我哋隨時行得喇
演員好了就過來
演員得就埋位啦
來了 演員出發
嚟緊 演員嚟緊
請問 現在拍的這場戲是描述什麼的
請問聲 而家呢場戲係描述啲咩㗎
可以的 拍完馬上告訴你
得㗎啦 拍完之後話你知呀
那你想我用什麼手法去演繹這個角色呢
咁你想我用咩手法去演繹呢個角色呢
好極了
無問題啦
就這麼說定了 演員到現場
一於係係咁話啦 演員到現場
就位
埋位
好 站著別動
好 企係度咪郁
你好
Hi
開機
開始
Action
停
Cut
好了 拍演員
Ok 拍演員
替身走開 演員就位
替身走開 演員埋位
替身走開 拉她出去
替身走 拖出去啦
快點
快啲啦
走開走開
行開行開
開始
Action
我不怕 你們就打死我吧
我唔驚 你地就打死我啦
停
Cut
好了
Ok
繼續打
演員休息 替身就位
演員休息 替身埋位
辛苦了 辛苦了
辛苦哂 辛苦哂
- 來了 - 抬起頭來
嚟啦 齕起個頭啦
抬起頭來
齕起個頭
- 醒醒啊 - 手舉起來
喂 舉起手
手指舉起來 幹活了
喂 舉起個手指呀 搵食呀
撐好 不要縮
頂住呀 唔好縮呀
開始
Action
停
Cut
換演員
開始
Action
想不到你們真的打死我
估唔到你哋真係打死我
- 停 - 停
- Cut - Cut
非常好
七個小矮人終於為白雪公主報了仇
七個小矮人終於為白雪公主報左仇
真的很感動
真係好感動
導演
我不是演白雪公主的嗎
我唔係演白雪公主㗎咩
你幹什麼
你搞咩
走走走
- 對不起 導演 - 快點拖她出去
- 對唔住 導演 - 快啲拖佢出去
導演
不好意思導演
唔好意思導演
準備拍白雪公主
收到
馬老師
叫那個過氣明星快點 全村人在等他
叫嗰個過氣明星快啲呀 全村都等緊佢呀
說誰過氣
邊個過氣呀
我
說話小心點
講嘢小心啲呀
是
係
閃開閃開 馬老師來了
閃開閃開 馬老師嚟啦
拍完這場就轉場
拍埋呢場就轉場
導演 女版白雪公主你選哪個
導演 女版白雪公主你揀邊個
漂亮點就好 只有一個鏡頭
揀個靚啲得㗎啦 得一個鏡頭啫
馬老師來了 大家冷靜點
馬老師嚟啦 大家冷靜啲
注意了 大家閃開 彈開
注意喇 大家閃開 閃開
大家借開 借開
大家借歪 借歪
不要湧過來 你還湧過來
唔好湧埋嚟 你仲湧埋嚟
大家冷靜點 不要亂來
大家冷靜啲 唔好亂嚟
不要摸 不要拍照
唔好摸 唔準影相
馬老師
我們今天這場戲是你演的白雪公主
我哋今日呢場戲係你演嘅白雪公主
被巫婆陷害
比巫婆陷害
你吃了毒香蕉之後變成了男人
你食左毒香蕉之後變左男人
王子喝多了 一時不為意
王子飲大左 一時唔為意
跟你睡了
同你上左床
是我睡他 還是他睡我
咁係我砌佢定佢砌我
都有
王子醒了後 發現你是男的
王子醒番之後 發現你係男人
沒有辦法接受 所以要把你殺掉
無辦法接受 所以要隊冧你
但是卻被你反殺
但係點知反比你隊冧
王子的所有手下到處追殺你
王子嘅所有手下四圍追殺你
你逃到了唐人街被砍了
你走到去唐人街被人砍
你身受重傷 連腸子都流出來了
你身受重傷連條腸都流埋出嚟
會不會太殘忍
會唔會殘忍左啲呢
其實我是想向張徹導演的暴力美學致敬
其實我係想向張徹導演嘅暴力美學致敬
張徹的暴力美學
張徹嘅暴力美學
您懂不懂
你曉唔曉
好啊
不是好 是懂不懂
唔係好 係曉唔曉
你覺得呢
你話呢
我不方便說
我唔係好方便講
我當然懂 腸都爆出來嘛
我曉梗係曉啦 腸都爆出來呀嘛
這個好 這個好
呢個好 呢個好
我們先拍你的腸爆出來 所以很生氣的反應 好嗎
我地先拍你啲腸爆出來 所以好嬲嘅反應 ok
好 準備
馬老師 我給你掛好這腸子
馬老師 我幫你掛埋條腸先
開機
第一次
Take One
開始
Action
我
我很生氣
我好嬲呀
停
Cut
馬老師可不可以真的生氣
馬老師可唔可以真係嬲
我都已經說我很生氣
我咪講左我好嬲囉
你們聽到嗎
你地聽唔聽到呀
只有你聽不到 我說出來了
係得你聽唔到咋喎 我都講到出口啦
難道是假的嗎
仲有假㗎咩
我不方便說
我唔方便講
不方便就不要說 誰逼你說
唔方便講唔好講 邊個逼你講啫
那能不能加點女人味
咁可唔可以加番啲女人味呢
我早就說了要加點女人味
我早就話要加啲女人味㗎啦
畢竟我是個公主
話晒我都係個公主嚟㗎嘛
等你說就死人了
等你就死得啦
來來來
come on come on
再來一次
one more time
開始
Action
我很生氣
我嬲到呢
我真的很生氣
我真係嬲到呢
搞什麼
哇搞咩呀
這什麼意思啊
咁咩意思啊
停 對白錯了
Cut 對白錯左
我去你的 你覺得我是在說對白嗎
我頂你個肺啊 你覺得我似係講緊對白咩
我的腸為什麼是火腿腸
我條腸點解係火腿腸嚟㗎
馬老師你聽我說 我們春節檔不能太殘忍
馬老師你聽我講 我地春節檔唔可以太殘忍
你剛剛不是都說爆腸定律嗎
你頭先唔係話爆腸定律㗎咩
是暴力美學 大件事了
係暴力美學 大件事啦
馬老師生氣了 大家要留意了
馬老師扯火啦 大家要留意啦
我剛才的演技都爆出來了
我頭先啲演技爆緊出嚟啦
你們為什麼不配合我呢
你地做咩唔配合我呢
因為我們的對象是家庭觀眾 有很多小朋友的
因為我哋嘅對象係家庭觀眾 有好多小朋友嘅
所以暴力美學中也要有天真可愛的感覺
所以暴力美學入面都要有天真可愛嘅感覺
我看到我自己的腸是一條火腿腸
咁我見到自己條腸係一條火腿腸
我會笑出來的
我會笑㗎嘛
怎麼投入呢
我點投入到呢
這些商業考慮真的很難給你解釋
呢啲商業考量真係好難解釋你聽嘅
你這麼偉大的演員
你咁偉大嘅演員
一條火腿腸難不倒你的
一條火腿腸難唔倒你嘅
當然難不倒我
咁梗係難我唔到啦
但你們真的太不尊重觀眾了吧
但係你地真係太唔尊重觀眾啊嘛
春節檔
要不要再加一個天真可愛的腎
咁駛唔駛呀 加多個天真可愛嘅腎添啊
道具 趕快多加一個腎 在
道具 嗱嗱聲加多個腎 係
收到 馬上做
收到 即做
導演 你覺得這個行不行
導演 呢個得唔得呀
加番茄醬看看
蘸啲茄汁睇下
好
嘩 又暴力又天真呀
是這意思
係咁嘅意思啊
大家準備 演員站好
大家準備 演員企好
去你的 還不叫停
頂你呀 仲唔 cut
累得要死
攰到仆街
大家注意了 注意了
大家注意啦 注意啦
馬老師來了 閃開 閃開
馬老師嚟啦 閃開 閃開
大家注意了 馬老師來了
大家注意啦 馬老師嚟啦
垃圾導演拍垃圾電影
垃圾導演拍埋啲垃圾戲
若是以前我早打他一巴掌了
比住我係以前大巴星佢啦
現在為什麼不打
咁你而家唔星佢
我現在有修養呀
咁我而家係有修養呀嘛
你笑什麼
你笑咩
你這傻瓜
你個蛤𧊅
你在笑我嗎
你笑緊我啊
我都沒笑你 你還笑我
我都未笑你 你走嚟笑我
我很好笑嗎
我好好笑咩
大家注意了 馬老師踢腳了
大家注意啦 馬老師起腳啦
沒開玩笑 馬老師踢腳了
唔講得笑呀 馬老師起腳啦
不要摸 不要拍照
唔好摸 唔好影相啊
控制一下自己
控制下自己
夢姐
真的是你
真係你呀
李洋
對啊
係呀
你這特效化妝
你嘅特技妝
是啊
係呀
剛剛怎麼回事
頭先咩事呀
沒事
無嘢啊
你吃我的吧
你食我呢盒啊
不用了
唔駛啦
對不起 帥哥
唔好意思啊 靚仔
我想再拿一個飯盒
我要多個飯盒得唔得啊
一人一盒
做臨時演員 還想著佔便宜
做個茄哩啡 都係度呃飯食
走
你下次再敢來 報警抓你
你下次再敢嚟呀嗱 我報警拉你啊
我上次就跟你們說過了
我上次都同你地講過㗎啦
人在做 天在看
你們為什麼要這樣
點解你地係都要咁嘅呢吓
什麼事
咩呀
飯盒做出來是不是讓人吃的
飯盒做出嚟係咪比人食嘅
說什麼
你嗡咩呀
你說
你講
答我
什麼答你什麼
咩呀答你咩啫
飯盒做出來是不是讓人吃的
飯盒整出嚟係咪比人食嘅
是啊 怎麼了
係呀 做咩啫
那為什麼她沒有
咁點解佢冇
誰是她
邊個佢呀
就是化了特效妝的女子
就係化特效妝嗰個女仔
答我
你說啊
你講啊
你冷靜點
你冷靜啲先
為什麼她沒飯盒 你鎮定點
點解佢冇飯盒 你定啲嚟呀喂
為什麼她沒有飯盒
點解佢冇飯盒
喂喂喂
你剛才為什麼拿個瓶子打自己
頭先你做咩用個樽鏗自己呀
難道我打他嗎
唔通我鏗佢呀
沒看到他多高大
你睇唔到佢幾大隻
有沒有見到女兒
有無見到個女呀
沒有
冇
這麼就走
就咁就走嗱
走
你知不知我 前幾天在劇組碰見馬可
你知唔知呀 前幾日我係劇組見到馬可
- 誰是馬可 - 馬可啊
- 邊個馬可 - 馬可啊
- 誰啊 - 算了
- 姐係邊個 - 唉是但啦
他那天不知是否心情不好 一腳把我飯盒打翻了
佢個日唔知係咪心情唔好呢 一腳踢左我盒飯落地呀
我去再要一盒 那帥哥死活不給
咁我咪想去攞過盒囉 阿靚仔又死都唔肯比喎
那我要走時 他突然又給我一盒飯
咁我走啦 咁點知佢又無厘頭比番盒飯我喎
你說我是不是開始走運呢
咁你話我係咪開始行運呢
你這個臨時演員會不會想太多了
你呢個茄喱啡會唔會諗太多呀
又不要看不起臨時演員
又唔好睇唔起茄喱啡
很多大明星都是由臨時演員做起的
好多大明星都係由茄喱啡做起嘅
孫儷 劉嘉玲 趙麗穎
你條件有她們好嗎
你條件有佢地咁好咩
我比她們還要好
我好過佢哋添啦
因為我比她們還要努力
因為我勤力過佢哋
你都神經病的
你都痴孖根㗎
總之 機會就是留給努力的人
總之呢 機會係留比努力嘅人嘅
不可能你站在大街上 就有人拉你當明星
唔通呀 你就咁企係條街度 就會有人埋嚟搵你做明星咩
小姐
有沒興趣拍戲
有無興趣拍戲呀
你是誰
你邊個嚟㗎
她是監製
佢係監製嚟㗎
你好 我是演員小夢
你好 我係演員小夢
你好 我們有一部戲正在找人
你好 我哋有一套戲而家搵緊人
有沒有興趣試一試
有無興趣試下
有 我很有興趣
有呀 我好有興趣呀
不好意思
唔好意思
不是你
唔係你
是你
係你
我
對 一直都是在問你
係呀 一路都係問緊你咋嘛
去試試吧 我們公司就在上面
去試下啦 我地公司就係上面之嘛
不要這樣
唔好咁啦
當作是玩就好
當係玩下咋嘛
不要哭
喊咩啫
他們選了我當女主角
佢地揀左我做女主角呀
真的
真㗎
我什麼都不會 選我幹什麼
我乜都唔識 揀我做咩喎
我進去他們要我把妝卸了 然後說了兩句對白
我入到去 佢地要我落左個妝 然後講兩句對白
那人就說是我了 我現在該怎麼辦啊
嗰個人就話係我啦 我而家點算好啊
什麼怎麼辦啊 多好的機會
咁點算好啫 咁好嘅機會
換作是我短五十年命 我都願意
如果比著係我短五十年命 我都制呀